Bitte schön.
Guten Abend. Mein Name ist Yu-Jel. Ich bin der Dienstabender auf dieser Station.
Ich möchte mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Sind Sie damit ein Zerstellmann?
Ja, guten Abend Herr Doktor. Wie ist Ihr Name?
Ich habe das nicht ganz verstanden, bitte.
Ja, mein Name ist Yu-Jel.
Yu-Jel? Was ist das für ein Name?
Was kommt das?
Ich schreibe wie Y-U-C-P-L.
Ja, woher kommt das?
Ich bin ein Schriftlaufer.
Ein Reporter.
Ich bin ein Deutsch-German.
Denen ist Yu-Jel.
Ah, der Schriftsteller.
Schriftsteller, ja.
Ach so, Sie haben den gleichen Namen.
Woher kommt der Name? Der ist aus der Türkei.
Die kommen auch aus der Türkei.
Ah, okay, sehr schön.
Ja, das ist im Moment sehr schwierig in der Türkei, mit der Politik.
Ja, zurzeit ist das eigentlich sehr schwierig.
Sie haben Recht.
Aber ja, es ist schön, dass Sie da sind.
Ich hoffe, Sie können hier schnell eine Arbeit finden.
Aber wir brauchen viele Ärzte.
Es ist schön, dass Sie gekommen sind.
Wir haben das gehört, deswegen sind wir da.
Wir wollen Ihnen immer helfen, in Deutschland alles hart zu arbeiten.
Ja, dann wünsche ich Ihnen viel Glück.
Was kann ich für Sie tun?
Ja, Doktor, ich habe aber ein Problem, deswegen bin ich hier.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Ich habe gehört, die Ärzte sind sehr gut.
Ja, ich werde Ihnen direkt helfen.
Bevor wir zu Ihrem aktuellen Bescheiden kommen,
möchte ich ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Person stellen.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Mein Name ist Susanne Reibach.
Ich möchte Sie bitte Ihren Namen bestabieren.
Susanne, ganz einfach.
Siegfried Udo, Siegfried Anton, Nordpol, Nordpol, Emi.
Susanne.
Nachname ist Reibach, Richard E. Mieda,
Bertha Anton, César Heinrich, Reibach.
Okay, Frau Reibach. Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 43 Jahre alt.
Wie alt sind Sie? Genau, geboren.
Wollen Sie auch noch wissen.
14. März 1980.
Darf ich fragen, wie viel Sie wiegen und wie groß Sie sind?
Das hat jetzt natürlich mit meiner Erkrankung nichts zu tun.
Aber wenn Sie das wissen wollen, kann ich Ihnen das gerne sagen.
Ich bin 1,65 m und wiege 68 kg.
Okay, Frau Reibach, was wirst du tun?
Herr Dr. Yücel, ich habe seit gestern Abend akute Bauchschmerzen.
Heute Morgen ist es stark geworden und schlimmer geworden.
Frau Reibach, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich habe das Gefühl, dass es am ganzen Bauch ist.
Aber es ist mehr im Unterbauch.
Aber es strahlt auch mal nach oben.
Es ist alles zu tun, aber es ist mehr im Unterbauch.
Ja, es tut überall weh, aber es ist mehr im Unterbauch.
Aber es strahlt auch mal nach oben.
Ich kann jetzt nicht sagen, dass es hier oder dort ist.
Es ist überall egal, wo man drückt.
Oder wo ich mit meiner Hand hin komme, tut es weh.
Ich habe das Gefühl, ich habe einen dicken Bauch.
Okay, Frau Reibach, wie stark sind die Schmerzen?
Auf einer Schmerzkala von 1 bis 10, wobei 1 sehr leicht zu sehen,
sehr starken Schmerzen entspricht.
Also, das hat gestern sehr leicht angefangen.
Aber heute Morgen ist es schon sehr, sehr stark geworden.
Deswegen bin ich gekommen.
Ich würde schon sagen, so bei 5, 6 wahrscheinlich.
Es ist schwer auszuhalten.
Und ich meine, dass ich auch, ja, es ist schon komisch.
Also, solche Bauchschmerzen hatte ich bisher noch nicht.
Könntest du bitte wieder open?
Ja, solche Bauchschmerzen habe ich bisher noch nie gehabt.
Also, das ist schon sehr gut gesagt.
Okay, Sie haben vorher keine ähnliche Beschwerden gehabt.
Nein, nein.
Sind die Schmerzen erst einmal aufgekriegt?
Ja, ja, würde ich schon sagen, ja.
Okay.
Wissen Sie, was die Schmerzen ausgelöst hat?
Nee, es war einfach da.
Ich kann nicht sagen, nein.
Okay.
Sind die Schmerzen plötzlich aufgetreten?
Oder hat...
Ja, das kam jetzt ganz plötzlich.
Aber er hat ganz langsam angefangen.
Und ist mehr geworden, ja.
Und da ging ein Gemäthramente eingenommen?
Ja, also gestern nicht, aber heute Morgen habe ich mir eine Parazitamol eingebrochen.
Ach, das ist in den Geholfen?
Eigentlich nicht, nein.
Okay.
Könntest du bitte die Schmerzen genau beschreiben?
Ist das ein drückender Siehende, Schwestechen oder Brennende Schmerzen?
Es ist von allem ein bisschen, was kann ich nicht genau sagen.
Also es ist wie gesagt eher im unteren Bereich, beim Bauchnabel.
Manchmal habe ich das Gefühl, es sticht mehr im rechten Seite.
Und manchmal ist es so auch ein bisschen wellenartig.
Und dann habe ich das Gefühl, der ganze Bauch ist ziemlich gebläht.
Also alles so komisch, ich kann es nicht genau schildern.
Okay.
Tunnen Sie bis Ende des Gesche-Presch-Beschmerzen aushalten?
Oder wollen Sie direkt eine Medikamente?
Ja, noch geht es, danke.
Ich glaube, wir machen erst mal vielleicht die Untersuchung fertig.
Ja, das wäre besser.
Verscheid geben, ja.
Okay, Frau Reibach, haben Sie Herzschmerzen, Brustschmerzen?
Nein, mit dem Herzen habe ich nichts.
Luftnot.
Ich fühle mich sehr komisch und geschwächt.
Ich habe das Gefühl, ich bin irgendwie schwer dank.
Okay, sind Sie momentan ein bisschen schwach?
Ja, ja, ja.
Okay.
Haben Sie bemerkt, dass Ihre Haut ein bisschen belästig ist?
Blass?
Blass, ja.
Ne, habe ich jetzt nicht.
Okay.
Haben Sie einen Unfall gehabt?
Nein, nein.
Haben Sie Fieber, Frau Reibach?
Ich glaube, heute Morgen, ich habe es nicht gemessen, aber...
Ich fühle mich sehr warm an und die Backen sind auch sehr komisch.
Also ich glaube schon, aber...
Okay, aber Sie haben nicht gemessen?
Nein, ich habe nicht gemessen, nein.
Okay.
Haben Sie Stilfrost oder Nachschweiß bemerkt?
Ja, heute Morgen.
Wenn Sie so fragen, ich habe das Gefühl gehabt,
ich habe so leicht eine Schüttelfrost gehabt heute Morgen.
Ist Ihnen übel oder schwindelig?
Eine leichte Übelkeit, glaube ich schon, das stimmt.
Aber Schwindel habe ich jetzt keinen, nein.
Okay.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen?
Nein, das darf ich.
Ne, ich habe keinen Brennen, keinen Ziehen.
Ist im Moment alles ganz gut, also da habe ich keine Beschwerden glücklicherweise.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Zugang?
Nein.
Also ich war jetzt seit gestern nicht auf Toilette.
Ich traue mich ehrlich gesagt auch nicht so,
weil ich denke, wenn ich auf Toilette gehe,
dass die Bauchschmerzen schlimmer werden.
Okay, aber haben Sie keine Verstopfung?
Nein, bisher, also bis gestern war alles noch völlig in Ordnung.
Okay.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit ungewohnt abgenommen oder zugenommen?
Nein, nein.
Alles gleich.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Also bis gestern war das sehr gut,
seit gestern habe ich wenig Appetit.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Schlafen?
Nein, bisher nicht.
Okay, Frau Reibach, haben Sie gestern unangenehm etwas gegessen?
Nein, es war eigentlich nichts Neues.
Also ich habe das, was ich üblicherweise normalerweise
zu Hause esse.
Ich koche auch immer leereber, immer frisch.
Also da war jetzt nichts Besonderes oder nichts Neues.
Ich habe jetzt Abend nur Reis gegessen und ein bisschen Salat.
Ja, sind die Schmerzen nicht essenabhängig oder?
Nein, nein.
Belastung abhängig?
Ich will jetzt nicht sagen, nein.
Okay, Herr Stehen.
Haben Sie etwas bemerkt, was die Schmerzen liegen werden oder versichern?
Ich habe gestern Abend eine Wärmeflasche auf dem Bauch gelegt.
Da wurde es ein bisschen besser, aber danach hat es auch nicht geholfen.
Okay, Frau Reibach.
Ist Ihnen vor Erkrankungen bekannt,
wie die Abitismenlutes Bruthochdruck oder Erhöftemlutes?
Ja, war ich gern gesund.
Ich mache wegen ein bisschen Sport.
Ich gehe immer zum Hausarzt, zu Kontrolle.
Meine Impfungen sind komplett.
Also ich achte eigentlich immer darauf,
dass ich bisher war, ich bin glücklicherweise nie ernsthaft krank.
Ich nehme oft keine Medikamente.
Nehmen Sie den Regen mit Medikamenten ein?
Nein, nein.
Ich habe keine Allergien, aber ich habe schon eine leichte Polenallergie.
Im Moment ist es wieder etwas verstärkt, aber ich habe jetzt keine Allergien.
Wie oberst du die Allergie?
Ja gut, es juckt in der Nase, meine Augen brennen.
Ich kriege manchmal schlecht Luft, aber da habe ich eine gute Tablette.
Eine Allergie-Tablette.
Wenn ich sie nehme, dann geht es mir wieder gut.
Was ist die Tablette?
Es sind sich Zetirezen.
Wie viele Medikamente und wie viele mal nehmen Sie?
Das weiß ich nicht.
Ich glaube, da gibt es nur eine Dosis.
Nehmen Sie nur eine.
Ein Nurweibedarf einer Tablette.
Zwei Reutwachter sind sich schon mal operiert worden.
Ja, als Kind. Da haben wir meine Mandeln entfernt.
Haben Sie noch andere Operationen?
Nein, bisher nicht.
Ich würde gerne ein paar Fragen zu Ihren Gewohnheit fragen.
Rauchen Sie?
Nein, ich rauche nicht.
Trinken Sie regiermäßig Alkohol?
Regelmäßig nicht, aber ich trinke ab und zu mal ein bisschen Wein.
Aber nicht regelmäßig.
Nehmen Sie nicht bei, dass es unangenehmer Routine ist.
Haben Sie Kontakt mit Drogen gehabt?
Mit Drogen? Nein.
Okay.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, ich bin verheiratet.
Und wir haben eine kleine Tochter, sie ist sieben Jahre alt.
Sieben Jahre alt.
Und ist sie gesund?
Ja, glücklicherweise.
Sie geht es gut.
Ich denke, wollen Sie mit Ihrer Familie zusammen?
Ja, wir wollen alle zusammen.
Okay.
Was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin ein Lehrer.
Ich bin ein Lehrer an einer Grundschule.
Ich bin Grundschul.
Okay.
Ja, ob Sie Regalmusik periort oder besuchen Sie Regalmusik
über Frau Nachts?
Also ich gehe da regelmäßig hin.
Normalerweise einmal im Jahr.
Bisher war alles in Ordnung.
Und meine Regel ist auch normal.
überhaupt keine Schwierigkeiten.
Okay, verstehe. Frau Reubach, ich möchte ein paar Fragen über ihre Familie stellen.
Sind ihre Eltern noch am Leben?
Ja, sie leben noch. Die sind gut.
Sie wohnen in Hamburg.
Sind sie gesund oder leiden sie an Bestände vor der Krankenhälfte?
Ja, halt.
Sie sind schon etwas älter, sind fast 70 Jahre jetzt alt.
Da haben sie schon ein paar Erkrankungen, aber das ist so weit alles in Ordnung.
Ich glaube, da nehmen sie Medikamente. Meinem Vater hat einen hohen Blutdruck.
Und meine Mutter leidet an so einer Schilddrüse.
Sie nimmt auch nicht ab, aber ihnen geht es eigentlich ganz gut.
Frau Reubach, ich bin falsch mit meinen Fragen.
Haben Sie Fragen oder wohnen Sie etwas, die zu fügen?
Ja, ich habe jetzt Angst, was es ist. Die Schmerzen werden schlimmer.
Ich hoffe, sie witten heraus und können mir beheflich sein.
Es macht mir jetzt ein bisschen Sorgen.
Ja, ich verstehe Sie sehr, aber es ist sehr früh etwas zu sagen.
Um eine genaue Diagnose stellen zu können, müssen wir zuerst Sie für politische Untersuchungen.
Dann müssen wir auch ein paar diagnostische Massnahmen durchführen.
Was machen Sie?
Nach dem körperlichen Untersuchung werde ich bei Ihnen Blut abnehmen.
Dann braucht man Ultraschall-Untersuchung.
Oder gegebenenfalls eine CT-Untersuchung durchführen.
Was ist eine CT?
CT ist eine diagnostische Massnahme.
Unter CT ist eine Computer-Tomografie.
Mit dieser Untersuchung können wir unsere Organe und GWB genau beurteilen.
Das ist ein strahlender Untersuchung, aber schmerzfrei.
Das dauert maximal 5 Minuten.
Nicht so stark?
Nicht so stark, das ist sehr weniger Strahlung.
Diese Strahlung ist für uns nicht gefeinlich.
Ich habe jetzt ein paar Informationen zu Untersuchung.
Sie haben die Patientin untersucht, sie hat Druckschmerzen im rechten Unterbauch.
Sie hat einen Loslassschmerz links, sie hat aber auch Druckschmerz epikastral.
Zudem hat sie einen sehr geblähten Bauch, da ist viel Luft drin.
Im Labor hat sie einen CRP von 260, Leukoziden 12000, Kreatinien, Leberwerte, Gamma-GT, alles völlig in Ordnung.
Im Mulch-Chall sehen sie normale Organe, Nieren sie in Ordnung, Gallenblase ist in Ordnung, Leber ist in Ordnung, keine freie Flüssigkeit.
Die Handblase ist in Ordnung, Urin ist in Ordnung.
Ich habe einen Kollegen, anderen Fragen.
Das war es von meiner Seite.
Frau Reiber, ich habe eine Frage.
Ja, bitte schön.
Was ist der letzte Regal Bluetooth?
Ah, die ist jetzt ungefähr zwei Wochen her.
Okay, danke.
Das war es.
Ich würde gerne eine Frage.
Können Sie genau beschreiben, am Anfang sind Tischenmerzen am Anfang an anderen Ort gewandert?
Nein, kann ich nicht sagen.
Es ist immer im Unterbauch meistens rechts gewesen.
Okay.
Ja, meine Frage.
Ja, bitte.
Ist es möglich, dass sie im Moment schwanger sind?
Nein, ich habe vor zwei Wochen meine Regeln gehabt.
Die war ein bisschen schwach, aber ich glaube nicht, dass sie jetzt schwanger sind.
Nein.
Aber man weiß es nicht.
Okay, Frage oder war es das?
Ich denke alle Fragen sind schon ab.
Können Sie erst mal beschreiben, am Anfang?
Okay.
Bitte schön.
Hallo, guten Abend Herr Överars.
Guten Abend, der junge Kollege aus der Türkei, der Jüchel.
Guten Abend, guten Abend.
Was kann ich tun, Herr Doktor?
Ja, so, ich bin.
Ich habe heute einen neuen Patient aufgenommen.
Ein Patientin?
Ich habe heute einen neuen Patientin aufgenommen.
Ich möchte diesen Fall Ihnen vorstellen.
Sehr gut, bitte schön.
Dann legen Sie mal los, erzählen Sie.
Ja, Frau Susanne Reibach ist eine 43-jährige Patientin, die sich seit gestern Abend bestehend hat.
Sie haben sich mit einer Form gestehend unter Bauchschmerzen vorstellt.
Sie haben sich mit einer Artigen und Stechenden unter Bauchschmerzen vorstellt.
Dann am Ende, dann nicht der, sondern dann.
Okay, weiter.
Okay.
Ich habe heute einen neuen Patientin, der sich seit gestern Abend bestehend hat.
Der Patientin zu folge sein, der Metheorismus, Stülphrost, Neuzia aufgefallen ist unaufwendig.
Die Patientin zu folgen, der Stülphrost, Neuzia aufgefallen ist, Stülphrost, Neuzia aufgefallen ist, Stülphrost, Neuzia aufgefallen ist.
Die Patientin zu folgen, der Stülphrost, Neuzia aufgefallen ist, Stülphrost, Neuzia aufgefallen ist.
Die Anamnistischen Angaben boten am Herstern auf Appendices hin.
Definanziell die Erklostisch-Kommun-Divertikulitis-Gastroenteritis im Betracht.
Rechte Unterbauchschmerzen, Divertikulitis?
Normalerweise können wir im linken Seite sehen, aber wahrscheinend ist das eine. Die Seite spricht dagegen. Sie haben Recht, aber wir müssen das auch ausschließen.
Was fällt Ihnen noch ein? Woran müssen wir noch differenzial diagnostisch denken?
Wir haben einige gemacht durchgeführt und wir wollen behamlen.
Worauf waren Sie? Sie denken, Sie hatten Appendices. Wollen Sie auch eine Computatomographie-Sicherheit über noch durchführen?
Ich würde gerne eine Computatomographie, eine Appendices zu ausschließen durchführen.
Was wollen Sie ausschließen?
Mit dem CT?
Ja, Momentan.
Sie haben gerade gesagt, Sie wollen mit dem CT ausschließen. Was wollen Sie ausschließen?
Mit dem CT.
Ja, Divertikulitis ausschließen.
Ja, okay.
Oder Sie wollen die Appendices bestätigen?
Ja, auch wenn wir eine Ultraschall-Uttersuchung nicht gefunden haben.
Welche Kollegen konsultieren Sie noch? Haben Sie die Chirurgien kontaktiert?
Ich habe noch nicht kontaktiert, aber ich würde gerne eine chirurgische Kursil fähren.
Welche Abteilung würden Sie noch kontaktieren?
Die Chirurgie.
Die Generelle.
Ich würde Sie noch etwas über die Differenzialdiagmosen sprechen.
Ich möchte noch 2-3 Differenzialdiagmosen hören.
Ich würde noch etwas über die Gravidat-Gravität denken.
Ja, extra Ultrarien-Gravität.
Extra Ultrarien-Schwangerschaft.
Bauchschwangerschaft und eine Eileiter-Schwangerschaft.
Woran denken wir noch bei Frauen?
Torsion.
Was noch?
Übertrags-Glasis.
Herr Gündnis, Sie sagen jetzt erst mal gar nichts.
Wo sind die anderen Kollegen? Ich möchte von anderen Kollegen wissen.
Bei Ihnen gebühren.
Also, was haben Frauen noch? Was kann das noch sein?
Endometriosis.
Ja gut, was noch?
Ganz einfach.
Oial-Sys-Porsion.
Oial-Syste, ja, wo war es noch?
At the next.
Wer hat es gesagt?
At next cities.
Ganz einfach, natürlich.
Das will ich hören.
Sehr gut.
Wohin muss man noch denken?
Nierenstein.
Leichtemernen.
Leichtemernen, sehr gut.
Sehr gut, auch ganz einfache Sachen.
Leichtemernen.
Richtig.
Woran denken wir noch?
Ein krone entzündliche Darmekrankung.
RBI.
Bitte?
RBI, Handel-Weg-Infektion.
Handel-Infektion.
Ja, also eine Infektion der ableitenden Hahnwege.
Kann auch noch sein, natürlich, auch wenn sie keine Beschwerden hat.
O-Varielles-Tid-Drehung.
Genau, eine Tosion hat der Kollege schon gesagt.
Okay.
Das ist eine Kulizistis.
Muss man auch immer denken bei einem Bauch.
Das stimmt.
Peritonitis.
Akutapdome.
Akutes Abdomen.
Also jegliche Bauchschmerzen.
Also die Definition von akutes Abdomen
ist jeder Patient mit Bauchschmerzen,
der in die Notaufnahme kommt, ist erstmal akutes Abdomen.
Uns hat man gesagt, akutes Abdomen
muss immer von einem Chirurgen angesehen werden.
Ja, aber okay.
Okay.
Die Patienten hat Roslarschmerzen.
Was für Schmerzen?
Roslarschmerzen.
Ja, ja.
Ja, genau.
Also diese Patientin, vielen Dank, das war sehr gut.
Herr Kollege, diese Patientin, die war vor zwei Wochen bei uns in der Praxis.
Die hat genau diese Symptome, genau diese Laborwerte.
Was glauben Sie, was ihr hatte?
Die hat keine Apendicitis.
Wir haben sie wegen Verdacht auf Apendicitis ins Krankenhaus geschickt.
Und was kam raus?
Eine Atnexitis.
Atnexitis.
Ich habe vor einer Woche einen Mann gehabt,
der mit ähnlichen Beschwerden auch Unterbauchschmerzen,
schon aber seit zehn Tagen,
ziehend Schmerzen in die Leiste ausstrahlend.
Was hat dieser Patient gehabt?
Der hat eine inkarzerierte Leistenherne.
Der hat also einen Leistenbruch gehabt und dann wird auch operiert.
Also Bauch ist ganz interessant immer.
Ja.
Die Patient fühlte die Patient, die Schmerzen im gesamten Abdohnung.
Aber die Leichter unter Bauch am Sten sein.
Ja, genau.
Und man muss immer daran denken, meistens kommen die Patienten,
die eine Apendicitis haben, mit Epigastradenschmerzen
oder Oberbauchschmerzen, mit Magenschmerzen.
Oft hat man auch bei Apendicitis Oberbauchschmerzen.
Deswegen, wenn jemand mit Oberbauch kommt,
muss man auch immer ein Apendix denken.
Manchmal schiebt Schmerzen auch Axelböle oder
rechten Apendicitis bei der Apendicitis.
Bei Atmixitis?
Axelböle, Axilla.
Ja, aber bei was?
Bei welche?
Ja, die Schmerzen von Atmixitis.
Echt? Reuchte nicht, kenne ich nicht.
Ja, kenne ich nicht.
Was sind Sie für ein Facharzt, Herr Kollege?
Neurologie.
Neurologie?
Das würde ich bei der Prüfung nicht sagen.
Bleiben Sie beim Bauch.
Leisten her, leisten in den grünen Bereich.
Richtig, aber in den axligen Bereich.
Das ist dann durchgefallen.
Bitte schön.
Ich glaube, bei Akutakulistitis, Schöthalien, Schmerzen,
die ich ausgleichen.
Das kann sein.
Herr Dr. Yücel, also.
Das ist voll schwer.
Glückwunsch, Sie sprechen sehr gut.
Langsam, deutlich machen Sie es sehr gut.
Ich denke, Sie werden die Prüfung, auch wenn es Bayern ist,
in Schalach bestehen.
Sie waren heute sehr gut.
Ich denke, das ist ein interessanter Fall.
Ich hatte bei meiner Prüfung im Staatsexamen
auch eine Appendicitis.
Vielleicht bekommen Sie die gleichen Fragen.